Bruce Partridge a Meredith professor of
astronomy in the science department at
haford college is a true Pioneer and
hero in the study of the cosmic micro
background he's one of the ogs but it
sure help establish the cosmic nature of
the radiation that enus and Wilson found
he was involved in the first
measurements of the CNB Spectrum to
confirm its true Cosmic origin that
result decimated the steady state theory
he was also one of the first scientists
to look for the smallscale temperature
fluctuations which provid gued us with
detailed insights into the distribution
of matter in the early Universe he's
made major contributions in both Theory
and experiment helping us understand the
cosmos turning cosmology into a
Precision science join us for an
exciting episode as we explore the early
Universe welcome everybody to another
exciting episode of the into the
impossible podcast featuring a friend a
colleague a collaborator and most
importantly a mentor in the space of
education and
of my field cosmologist generations of
them and that's Bruce Partridge who's an
Emeritus professor at haford College in
Pennsylvania how are you today Bruce
doing well e to talk to you yes it's
good maybe even at
you yes the internet is quite is quite
amazing allows us to do these things and
I am talking to Bruce because of many
things first of all he's a an incredible
scientist and amazing uh knowledge about
the field it's its past present and
maybe even its future having been
involved with some of the greatest
experiments of all time including
perhaps you know one of the first or
second experiments to really go after
the detection of the CMB and its
properties and Bruce was involved with
uh with my grand advisor so my grand
advisor was David Wilkinson and he
advised Peter timby and I'm still Peter
timby is soon to be hopefully
collaborating closely with us in the
Simons Pro projects as well so as I
talked to you earlier in the week we
always love to do a segment on this
podcast that represents something you're
not allowed to do you're not supposed to
do which is to judge a book by its cover
and you have two wonderful books um one
of which I read 30 years ago which is
called 3K so I've always been eager to
ask you how you came up with the title
um and the cover design because it
depicts the horse head nebula which to
my knowledge has nothing to do with the
three Kelvin background but maybe it
does so Bruce the clever title 3K was
mine I figured it would nice
abbreviation the Damned cover was
designed by Cambridge University press
it's part of a series and they all show
the horse said nebula which you're right
has nothing to do with the microwave
background at all I was thinking we
could talk about the nebula just for a
minute in that it's often said that I
think it was mckel had detected
properties of cyanide uh in the
interstellar medium uh and that
supposedly that was
um you know revelatory of a 3 Kelvin
background what do you make of that did
you know about those measurements what
what do you think about those
measurements in the early days 1940 the
situation is the following these little
Cyanogen molecules CN and Float around
in space but they appear to be excited
as though they were bathed in a roughly
3 Kelvin field of radiation they're not
at zero temperature they're at 3 Kelvin
3 degrees above absolute zero or roughly
5° Fahrenheit above absolute zero this
is written down back in the 30s and 40s
and it was described by the discoverer
as a being of some interest but George
field among other peoples remembered
reading that paper and then when penus
and Wilson found the 3 Kelvin radiation
he he
recognized that that 3K 3 Kelvin
radiation might be responsible for the
excitation of Cyanogen and that gave us
a measurement at a particular wavelength
of 2.6 millimet wasn't very precise but
it sure helped establish the cosmic
nature of the radiation that pus and
Wilson found that's right now I look at
a lot of your research and you have uh
you have an H index I think it's the um
you know the cube of mine or something
like that or number of papers and
citations that number close to 100,000
which is which is just astounding and I
I've gone through many of them because
they're all treasures and little
diamonds and they're not so rough many
of them are incredibly readable but I
want to ask you about when I think of
the Bruce Partridge brand I think very
high quality Theory but always attached
and never divorced from experiments from
the very beginning can you talk about
your philosophy as a as a scientist to
couple together Theory and experiment is
very hard to do but you managed to do it
can you give us tips to Mortals like me
how did you manage to cultivate that is
that a intention by intentionality
experiments like blank act now the
Simon's Observatory what is that
philosophy that's has guided you in in
terms of the theory side I was
interested in a field that was
interesting but fairly simple if you go
back to the 60s cosmology was simple uh
we we didn't know anything so it was a
very simple subject to get into and that
extended also to my abilities and
interest in in the experimental side
when I showed up at Princeton as a poock
there were two experiments going on one
was the most famous One namely looking
at the microwave background and trying
to establish that it was Cosmic and the
other was measuring the shape of the sun
because Bob Dicky had a theory that
would call on the sun to be somewhat
oblate squished in its in its properties
so I went down to look at the solar
oblateness experiment a whole room full
of
electronics no too complicated I went to
look at the microwave background there
was a whole went into wave guide I knew
about wave guides went into detector I
knew about detectors so I signed up for
that so it was this sort of search for
Simplicity and stuff that I thought I
could do and those early experiments uh
when when reputedly what what year did
you arrive at at Princeton as a as 65
was right around the time of the three
months after the paper was published
that that established the microwave
background so it was it was early days
now I've read that paper you know many
times not not and and the companion P I
Always call the penes and Wilson paper
the companion paper because the
companion the penes and Wilson paper is
only I think it's less than a full page
in the appj
it's I mean they they were being very
careful I said yeah we found this signal
it's as though everywhere we look we're
looking at a surface of three degrees
above absolute zero not zero but 3
degrees above and they didn't interpret
it the crucial moment as you just point
pointed out was the interpretation that
this is the heat cool down heat left
over from The Big Bang and that was in
the dicky PE rooll in Wilkinson paper
that you probably heard a million times
as I have that one is incredible and in
um many times when I read it I point out
it it doesn't nowhere do the words Big
Bang appear but instead the the collapse
from a previous Epoch appears almost as
if they kind of thought that it might be
more likely that there there was a
obviously formation of the nuclei but
they didn't necessarily believe that it
was the origin of time or perhaps
something like that take us back to
those uh to that year that magical year
in cosmology we're coming up on the what
60th anniversary I can't believe it
close too yeah yeah so tell me what was
that roughly speaking what was going on
the Zeitgeist the spirit of the times
back then so going back to the 60s there
were basically two competing theories
other speakers in this series may have
mentioned that but one was steady state
in which the universe was always the
same everywhere the same and always the
same and in order to keep the density
the same you had sort of Pop electrons
and protons up out of nothing and
competing with that was the Big Bang
Theory uh the universe had a finite
beginning uh it just started and the
suggestion
was most proponents The Big Bang Theory
accepted this that would also be a hot
big bangang so those two things were in
the air and dicki and his colleagues
were in a sense trying to push them
together a little bit by imagining an
infinite Universe in time that simply
cycled it expanded then it contracted
then it expanded then it contracted and
that Universe had to be hot for the
following reason in any one of these
phases of the universe stars make heavy
elements and after many cycles you'd
have nothing left at heavy elements the
universe would consist of nothing but
iron and nickel and it doesn't so to get
rid of the heavy elements you have to
have a hot big bang which boils them
away turns them back into their
constituent neutrons and protons so
there's a built-in you had to have heat
in this model and what's interesting was
that the prinson guys are actually
setting out to find this they had built
a piece of equipment specifically
designed to look for heat left over from
the
bang when the Fateful telephone call
came from these two guys excuse me I'm
just going to be informal hold up a
picture here of course no there they are
these are the two guys penius and Wilson
uh and behind them the horn radio
telescope that first noticeably detected
the
radiation so they got in touch with the
Princeton group and the story repeated
in your book Brian is that Dicky was
meeting with his young colleagues this
is before just before I got there put
his hand over the phone and said well
boys we've been scooped benzes and
Wilson had found a
signal uh that looked like it might be
heat left over from The Big Bang as
Dicky and Company were predicting
important is that the Princeton
experiment was specifically designed to
look for this heat so very quickly
within a year it had produced better
results than penius and Wilson and cons
consistent with the original Discovery
but again Brian as you point out in your
book the Nobel Prize went to benus and
Wilson and not the dicki and W Wilson
and pebles well pees got his later but
yeah that's right recently and uh pebles
of course is the co-author in one of
your early papers we'll talk about that
in a minute but I've always found the
saddest story uh the saddest person in
the whole Affair was this guy Ed M oh I
I don't know much about him but uh but
other than that he used the very same
horn antenna at Hell which is a National
Historic Landmark um and also uh did
several of the same types of experiments
that use similar types of radiometers
but the one thing he was missing was a
was a internal calibrator that could
check at rapid rates to get rid of the 1
over F signal and of course we know that
by the name of your advisor uh as a
Dicky switch and so they employed the so
the dicky switch really is the thing
that but Ed is not blameless in this
whole affair because if you go over his
technical report in the Bell Labs
telephone systems Journal which I read
many times many years ago he does a a
thorough eror analysis and then there's
a three Kelvin term and he counts that
to the to the atmosphere to the intenna
temperature it's really not clear to me
I think novakov and others later point
also saw that term even before pensy and
Wilson so they're kind of a lesson that
I teach to my undergraduates that a
analysis seems annoying but it's very
important you get it right and that you
account for all those errors and that's
that's one of the things that pus and
Wilson did very very well they saw the
signal they didn't say we've seen a
signal I'm going to publish it in the
astrophysical journal they busted their
butts trying to show that it was not
radio stations from New York or PID poop
in that horn which would also radiate
and cause a signal they they were very
careful om I think didn't make those
same steps and the Russians who read 's
paper unlike the Princeton group made
the mistake of assuming that what om was
seeing was the atmosphere where it
wasn't it was an addition to the
atmosphere so 1930s cyanogens floating
around in space kept warm by something
nobody paid any attention
M uh Jasper wall did a radio astronomy
experiment in which looking at the
Spectrum of emission from our galaxy
seemed to show that there was a sort of
additional term that he couldn't
explain equal to 5 Kelvin so there were
hints and I I like to make the point
that what changed from hints and so on
to a prediction was that paper by by the
princi group they went out on the limb
and said this stuff is Cosmic and origin
and then the next couple of years Dave
and I and other people work to try to
pin that down by doing two tests if I
may go on for a moment the first was a
spectrum that is if there's heat left
over from The Big Bang you should get
the same temperature 3 Kelvin or
whatever at every single wavelength you
measure and we set up a series of
experiments that prove that you did and
incidentally got a better value for the
temperature it's now 2.7 is closer and
the other is that if if this stuff is
left over from the beginning of the
universe the beginning of the universe
is everywhere around you in any
direction which you look out you're
seeing back in time so this radiation if
it's Cosmic and origin ought to be
isotropic that is the same in all
directions penes and Wilson had checked
a seed that wasn't coming from New York
City or Philadelphia or the center of
our galaxy but the limits they set on
it I srop be whether it's the same in
all directions were pretty
poor and Dave and I recognize it with
fairly simple equipment we get improve
it by a couple of orders of magnitude
and we did Houston we have a problem
YouTube analytics tells me that only 15%
of you are actually subscribed to my
channel your subscription mean means a
lot it lets me know that you're enjoying
the content and keeps you in the loop
with the latest episodes and updates
plus it's a win-win you supporting me
helps me support you by getting best
possible guest in the known universe so
hit that subscribe button now back to my
chat with Bruce and one piece of advice
I'd love to get we have a lot of young
listeners PhD students even graduate
students uh I've been working in the
field of CMB B mode polarization for you
know 25 years almost by now and we have
yet to see we we well we saw signal in
2014 but of course we had to recant that
signal now or the interpretation of it
still accurately measured highly
accurate and dominated by astrophysical
not man-made or Earthbound systematic so
it's an incredible accomplishment still
is the most sensitive measurement how
did you go through the years so this is
partially a question from one of your
former students by the name of Professor
Stefan Alexander and I asked him for a
question for you today and he asked me
essentially how did you have the the
sort of courage or or how did you have
the patience to do the first sorts of
anisotropy measurements as you did to
see if it was isotropic and not really
see fruition until David Wilkinson and
and George Schoo and and and others um
measured the anisotropy convincingly I I
would say the Spectrum was known by you
to be very close and others uh to black
body or or it was very easy but the
anisotropy was completely upper limits
after upper limits for almost 30 years
how did you have the courage and
patience to deal with that give me
advice to kind of uh keep patient
because it's been longer since the
between the detection of the CMB and its
first anisotropy than it has been from
its first anisotropy to measuring B mode
polarization how can I have patience or
what can you advise my students and I to
do in terms of coping with decade after
decade perhaps of upper limits when do
we give up don't this is this is the one
word advice but remember back in the 60s
and even into the 7s the idea was not to
find anisotropies because frankly we
weren't listening to the theorists and
didn't really understand how rich the
the field of anisotropies could be
instead it was a different aim and that
is to show that the radiation was in
fact isotropic it's easy to imagine
let's say Starlight being thermalized by
dust and emitting at the 3 Kelvin level
it's easy to imagine indeed it was
suggested by many people but that would
tend to be brighter towards the plane of
the Galaxy than perpendicular to the
plane of the Galaxy so our aim was not
initially to find anisotropies but not
to find them to set better and better
upper limits and if I can hold up
another thing
here uh here's a plot this is again this
is rather informal but a plot of
measurements of temperature and you
notice the scale over here is in
thousands of the Kelvin yeah and this
this was a very
crude experiment with lousy Dicky
switching which we set up first on on a
tall building at the Princeton
University campus and then realizing
that New Jersey weather is not ideal we
took it out to Arizona and ran it it was
run remotely for a couple of years
uh the the Arizona location involves
some interesting stories da Wilkinson
discovered that Yuma Arizona is the
sunniest place in the United
States I discovered through my military
father that there was an Army base there
that's right Proving Ground The Yuma
Proving Ground and further research
showed that there was a very secure area
where we could put this piece of
equipment about the size of a small Hut
out in the desert and not have it
bothered and it was Secure because the
Army was busy testing nerve gas shells
the idea was you build big wooden rocks
put a bunch of nerve gas shells in and
wait to see if they leak needless to say
that area was fenced and patrolled so I
I shouldn't feel bad about sending my
graduate students you know to Chile for
three weeks where their active mind
Fields much more
interesting we were issued gas masks and
we were told that there were certain
physiological signs and if you notice
those it was probably too late to put on
the gas mask so so instead the
monitoring system was rabbits I promised
you to quock about the rabbits yes so
the rabbits were stationed in hutches
around these nerve gas shells and the
idea was if it started the nerve gas
started to leak the rabbits would
die well about halfway through our time
there the rabbits started to die so
there was a big fuss all kinds of tests
we weren't allowed in for a while got
quite complicated and it eventually
turned out that the nerve gas wasn't
leaking but the Army and its wisdom had
bought three dozen rabbits all of the
same
age so we happened to to have been there
at the time when the rabbits reach three
score in 10 years and were beginning to
curl up
natural what we were able to show is
there's some scatter back and forth but
there no excursions that are bigger than
about a third of a percent of the micro
background so no evidence
that the radiation was coming from a
particular
place strong support for the cosmic
interpretation by 1968 or so and the
original paper P Wilson and subsequent
ones by by you guys at at Princeton the
topic of polarization was broached
actually as early as uh 1967 well in '
65 pen Wilson set a limit of 10% or
unpolarized below 10% and then in
1967 I believe it was uh Martin Reese
Lord Martin Ree now who's a three-time
guest on this podcast he came out with a
paper uh that suggested the CNB could be
polarized in fact it could be highly
polarized and that was based in the
model that the uh that the Big Bang or
the Hubble expansion could be
anisotropic it could have an you know an
anisotrophy to it that would generate a
quadriple moment in the photons so it'd
be a huge quadriple moment in the cmbs
anisotropy and that would generate a
large amount of polarization and I like
to point out when when I talk to him
that you know he was right but for the
wrong reasons uh but that that actually
has a lot in common with a lot of what
science is about uh for example Galileo
believed that the Earth orbited around
the sun we know that's true but he used
the title pattern of the Earth's Tides
as an piece of evidence for sloshing and
swirling of tides and has nothing to do
with that so can you comment on you know
how sometimes incorrect theories can
generate useful scientific tests and
sometimes detections and obviously I'm
going to Pivot to inflation and dark
matter and string theory in just a bit
but talk about how how much should an
experimentalist listen to a theorist my
first answer would be in this field at
least not enough and I'll come back to
that but first let me talk about the
polarization business the detector that
Dave Wilkinson and I used wasn't
intrinsically polarized so had there
been a huge signal in polarization we
would have seen it in addition in
Reese's paper in order to make a big
polarized signal not not a tiny one you
have to have an anisotropic universe and
that would have resulted in a sort of
dipole potato shaped sausage shaped
temperature distribution in the sky
which we didn't see the polar ation that
we do see now is from a much subtler
effect there is a small quadruple moment
which we do expect and that produces the
roughly tenth of a percent type
polarization that we detect in the M
background I said earlier that we should
have listen to the
theorist a little bit more because so
many of the early people in this field
came out of Bob Dicky's group and Bob
Dicky was an absolute Master at null
experiments showing that
such and such was smaller than certain
value the time rate of change of the
gravitational constant was below one
part and into the 12 and so on and so
forth a lot of our experiments were
designed to be null experiments and we
weren't particularly interested in
finding something and we didn't
particularly pay attention to the
theorists who were telling us if you're
looking for small variations in the
temperature you ought to be looking on
scales of the order of a degree or below
and that's reflective in the design of
the Kobe satellite which you know
about the experiment that won George
Smoot his Nobel Prize was consciously
designed to look for small changes in
temperature different parts of the sky
but at a wrong scale at 10 degree scale
instead of one degree scale we could
have
done much better might even have found
the anisotropies earlier had the
experiment been designed better and had
George and the rest of us listen to the
theorist we are busy trying to get lower
and lower limits yes it's natural to do
that I guess the question you know that
comes up all the time with me and and
there seems to be obviously there is
group think in any organization of
individuals just because they have uh
incentives to maybe um you know combine
or or or be be related to those in their
field that are setting the trends and so
forth so nowadays uh you see a lot of
more string the than people looking at
things like Loop quantum gravity or some
other alternative that could be
plausible so too I worry that there are
an awful lot of people invested in
inflation and I wonder are there
parallels that you see as an observer
both then and now between the dominance
of a theoretical Paradigm and the um
cultural pressure for young people to go
into that field either as
experimentalist in my case or as
theorist in in in others cases I don't
buy the argument about the social
pressure there's a sort of standard view
yeah inflation is important and of
course it is consistent with a lot of
things we're finding including isotropy
but when I read of a a new experimental
result my very first reaction is how can
I show this is wrong can I do a simple
experiment to show that it's wrong I'll
give you an example I was sent a paper
to review which claimed that because of
some complicated Theory there had to be
a strong an isotropy in the Gamay
background so I did the calculation and
discovered that if I simply held up a
plate full of raw
eggs the gamma rays that this guy was
predicting would be present would cook
it instantly I think a lot of us have
that sort of skeptical how can I show
this is wrong attitude and are not
terribly
hidebound by the sort of prevailing
Orthodoxy let's call it and you look at
your adviser Dicky I don't think he gets
enough credit for comp you know the
contributions first of all he was an
Exemplar of a of what I think of as the
Paradigm of a physicist like a fery or a
Galileo in that he knew the theory and
he could do experiments too and that's
extremely rare um we'll talk about later
your philosophy on pedagogy but one of
the things that dicki contributed to the
theory of inflation was I think he
pointed out and correct me if I'm wrong
Bruce to a young Alan goth that there
was this you know kind of cosmic
Coincidence of the flatness of the
universe not knowing that it was exactly
flat but knowing knowing it was within
an order of magnitude of being flat can
you talk about that that kind of um
those Notions and why it wouldn't be
inflation that I would first think to
sort of want to explain it would be
probably the missing you know Barons or
missing M what what made that stand out
so much to to your advisor to Bob Dicky
if you can speculate obviously he's not
here anymore I I will have to speculate
but it's the following take two parts of
the
universe that are very far
apart suppose one part of the universe
wants to tell another part of the
universe what to do for instance point a
wants to tell point B what temperature
to be that information can't travel
faster than the speed of light so on
very large scale
there's no way that one part of the
universe knew to be 3 Kelvin and another
part of the universe knew to be 3 Kelvin
unless it was an initial condition and
you don't like initial conditions you
don't like to have to say well the
universe started out in just such a way
that it's now 3 degrees Kelvin so how do
you explain that and that worried dicki
he was worried about that he was worried
about Mock's principle and some other
things that have to do with these large
scale properties and puzzles in the
universe
and what Allan goose and Company did was
basically to explain it and that is to
say that at some earlier time the
universe was so small that regions that
are now too far apart to talk to each
other were perfectly happy in
confabulation early on and then the
universe expanded exponentially which we
call inflation so the fact that
the back to this picture which I keep
shoving because this this picture shows
you that the universe is pretty much the
same in all directions well how did it
know on a large scale to be the same in
all directions it had to be in contact
causal contact to use a technical word
at some early time and that's that's
what's behind inflation is to get that
done going back to the same year in
1967 I pulled up a a paper which is
still getting
citations uh from uh a young Bruce
Partridge and uh young Jim Peebles and
it's called are young galaxies visible
and you talk about the purpose of this
paper is to assess the general
population possibility of observing
distant newly formed galaxies to this
end a simple model of Galaxy formation
is introduced and you talk about star
foaming and their luminosity and then
you say they these bright phases would
correspond to an Epoch of a few uh tens
or hundreds of millions of years
corresponding to a red shift between 10
and 30 I want to talk about recent um
so-called claims or discoveries or
controversies as our British friends
might say regarding the seeming
observation of very mature galaxies at
very high red shift much higher than
than ever anticipated and for this I I
am old enough that I can actually
remember the controversies that
similarly seem to erupt after the Hubble
Deep Field was released in 95 or so that
was in the middle of my graduate student
career beginning of it so I want to ask
you what do you make of these of these
findings and controversies I mean are
they just not reading your paper this
paper that you wrote In other words
these scientists are saying that the
Universe must be much older than we
previously thought possibly even Eternal
uh because the galaxies that we see are
two highly organized Grand designs and
Spirals and so forth you showed almost
again 60 years ago 54 years ago that
this was possible what's going going on
here okay well this goes back to the
previous discussion where we talk about
a sort of Orthodoxy the Orthodoxy these
days on Galaxy formation it's probably
correct but let's question it is that
galaxies are built up by mergers of
little things so you start with a bunch
of little things they merge together
that blob merges with another blob and
pretty soon you've got a Galaxy the
problem is that you've got to do that
really really fast to explain mature
galaxies very early in the history of
the universe approach that pebles and I
took was very different and that is a
blob of
gas of Gala Galactic Mass collapsed in
on itself and started to form Stars so
you went from nothing or relatively
smoothly distributed gas to a Galaxy not
by merger maybe there was some something
in that after all maybe that's how these
mature systems do form it's always
interested me that the way you find that
a Galaxy
is at large red shift and is star
forming is to look for a Sharp
discontinuity in the Spectrum introduced
by the Lyman Lyman break which is in
that paper what may be going on is that
galaxies form in special places more
like the Partridge people's model but
not
universally and that merges are
responsible for most galaxies but not
the ones that the web is finding or that
these galaxies look bigger and more
massive than they actually are and that
is a possibility but it is sort of fun
to argue with the with the conventional
Orthodoxy because if you start with
things that are let's say a million
times the mass of the Sun you merge two
of them you get something that's 2
million times the mass of the Sun and
then you have to merge again and get
something that's four million times the
mass of the Sun and then 8 million and
how the hell do you get something that
is pushing a billion times the mass of
the Sun in the time that's allowed
you're uh more on the iconic clastic or
Maverick side of things which is enjoy
it yeah which is which is fun to do but
it's it's tough to first of all you have
to have the prerequisites to get to that
level and I feel like these guys that
are criticizing or saying the Big Bang
never happened like U Eric larner and
even um re Renda scupa at University of
Ottawa you know published the universe
is 26 billion years old um they all sort
of rely on on you know kind of a series
of Just So Stories but they can always
point to flaws in the in the Big Bang in
especially in the early Universe
cosmology because every model will have
its laune and I think obviously you know
the Big Bang does too I would say of all
the ones that are pointed out by learner
and Gupta and others uh the one that
still is sort of in question that I'd
like to get your take on although you
know I don't think this has been a field
of study for you but it's the lithium
abundance problem that there seems to be
the largest gap between predicted
abundances in the BBN um you know kind
of taxonomy and observed uh the biggest
one Exton is in lithium can you talk
about that is that something we we
should be concerned about or is this
just messy nule clear physics that the
guys that operate you know giant vandag
graphs will someday figure out what what
do you make of the lithium problem as
this proves the Big Bang never happened
I think it's a very weak read in which
on which to claim that you've disproven
the Big Bang just to set some context
the early Universe starts out it's it's
hydrogen neutrons little bit of helium
and a tiny tiny amount of lithium is
produced as a sort of byproduct but
lithium is a fragile nucleus it's can be
made in cosmic ray interactions so it
it's
not all that convincing as a as a proof
or dispro of the Big Bang the detarium
abundance on the other hand is very
important and what's interesting to me
is that nuclear physicists Guided by
people like Jim Peebles and Bob wager
were predicting how much detarium and
how much helium should emerge from The
Big Bang and we discover exactly that
amount and the amount of dyum is
consistent with a very small amount of
ordinary matter in the universe which
the microwave background also emphasizes
so lithium is sort of a to me a side
issue can be made it can be destroyed in
Stars so it's it's a little again just a
weak read on which to undermine so much
other observational evidence on your
website which we'll link to in the video
description below you um have a nice
discussion of you know the research
interests that you have had and
maintained and it concludes with one
statement that careful measurements of
these CNB fluctuations both from space
and the ground have turned cosmology
into a Precision science I had uh Mike
Turner on who I know you know and he
said uh not about you but he's he's
famous for saying you know Precision
cosmology is nice but accurate cosmology
is better uh I wonder if you can um talk
about are there things that's are still
outstanding maybe not Mysteries but
there's further research in areas of the
CMB that might be considered to have
been a closed book and I'm thinking
about distortions I'm talking about
Compton why I'm talking about uh
chemical potentials are there still
things of interest that a young student
might be able to contribute to in that
particular field yes I think so both in
terms of spectral distortions which is
what you're mentioning but to me much
much more interesting in a sense is is
pushing harder and harder and harder on
the visible anisotropies if I can just
scoot it aside for a while here's a map
of the sky uh and these regions of red
and blue are slightly higher and
slightly
cooler
regions of the micro background studying
those has proven to be an absolute
Bonanza in terms of refining
cosmological theories as an instance if
you look at that picture carefully
you'll see that there's quite a lot of
structure at roughly the one degree
scale yeah and less at two degrees and
less at half a degree well why should
that be well it turns out that that is
exactly what you expect
from the size of the universe at the
time we're mapping it provided the
universe has a flat spatial curvature
and not otherwise so simply finding
where the peak is in terms of the
distribution of fluctuations tells you
about the curvature of the universe
you've already mentioned the B modes
we're looking for those at the small
scale end the way structure forms in the
universe can
distort the micro background
fluctuations a little bit not much but
because the measurements are now so good
uh we can put constraints on things like
the speed at which gravity pulls matter
together to make galaxies and so on and
there are fortunately for young people
in the fields still some some
interesting tensions um You probably
talked about this before but if you ask
how fast the universe is expanding if
you'd ask that question in
1960 you'd get two answers from two
Waring groups groups one claiming it was
expanding twice as fast as the other and
it got to the point where if you ever
had a meeting dealing with cosmology you
had to invite one person from each group
where they'd get poed now the debate is
between the Supernova guys who are
claiming a number that's about
10% different from the number that Brian
and CMB folks are claiming I don't think
we're at the point where you have to
have one from each school at each
cosmology but there's a real tension
there the difference between 67 in the
standard units and 73 in the standard
units is three or four times the error
so something isn't right somewhere and
that needs to be sorted out and the rate
of growth of structure how fast gravity
pulls things together is also somewhat
in
dispute remark to Brian this is the S8
or Sigma 8 to so there's still work to
be done yeah and I see that as yeah yet
one of many tensions and I I just had
the opportunity to to visit my alma moer
which is Case Western last week and I
met with um a friend of mine who wasn't
a professor until a couple years after I
graduated and that was Glenn starkman
and uh he is is making a very convincing
case that based on that image behind you
that you helped to make I believe that's
from plank um and you were map I think
but that's W map okay well plank did the
very very upgraded and beautiful um and
complimentary and also in strong
agreement with the wmap map so there's
plank yeah
beautiful I'm I'm partial to WAP because
it has my grand advisor's name as the
first and I'm sure your friend David
Wilkinson is uh nice to be uh located in
L2 I pointed he'll probably be orbiting
the universe uh forever his name's sake
instrument uh but Glenn has pointed out
that if you take that image behind you
and you put it that's in Galactic
coordinates I assume but if you kind of
rotate 45° it turns out it's an ecliptic
coordinates and he says that if you take
uh and you make a power spectrum of uh
or correlation function not a power SP
but of the uh data in the northern
ecliptic Hemisphere and you compare it
to the southern ecliptic Hemisphere and
this was pointed out by our good friend
David spurgle back in 2003 from those
data behind you so I know that for a
fact that there's an asymmetry there's a
big asymmetry between the statistical
properties of the North South hemisphere
barely visible here but this is looks a
little rder than up there that's exactly
right and there are things like the cold
spot interestingly enough the axis of
Evil SoCal we'll talk about that in just
a second but the cold spot is in the
southern he ecliptic Hemisphere and that
seems to agree with what you'd get from
a gaussian random simulation based on
Lambda CDM but the north isn't the north
you only get in if you account for
everything I think with the latest plank
data uh Glen uh Glenn student
uh Joanne was showing me this last week
there's only a
0.2% chance it arises at random if
you've been around this a long time what
do you make of these kind of U these
asymmetries are we trying to demand too
much of this big bang Bonanza that is
the CMB is it really fair to AC to ask
for it to be accurate and precise at the
two hundredths of a percent level that
may be pushing it um
and again as you well know the sort of
standard explanation for the hot spots
and the hemispheric
asymmetry is basically goes back to
playing poker any given hand that you're
dealt is highly unlikely I mean not just
a royal straight flush but you know a
two of spades a three of clubs blah blah
blah any particular thing is unlikely
but it has to be something yeah and so
some of that point
o2% is covered by Cosmic variance just
the universe happens to be that way so
it doesn't keep me up at night well I
would love to see someone
actually improve the measurements or
figure out how to beat Cosmic variants
to see if there's something that's
statistically odd about the microwave
background at large scales again I'm
like kind of clastic but not losing
sleep over that unlike losing sleep over
the the rate of expansion of the
universe and the growth of structure
those worry me are there other
explanations that you prefer for say
explaining the Hubble tension I'm quite
partial and I want to explain my
reasoning because I'd love to get your
opinion as one of the heroes and and
legends in the field but my my
philosophy of experiments and even
theories is that you should always do
very extremely risky science on the one
hand with one of your hands but the
other hand you should do something
that's known to exist and known to be
there such that the whole thing is not
an empty uh Pursuit I always laughed
when my colleagues in high energy
physics down the hall would say the most
exciting thing we could discover with
the Large Hadron Collider is nothing and
I would say yes and then you will
discover unemployment but um so it was a
big gamble but it was also safe on the
other hand that we sort of had a good
idea I I like to do searching for the
the cosmic microwave backgrounds B modes
because uh they may be there it's
extremely highrisk science they may not
be there even if inflation took place
and then on the other hand like to do
very lowrisk stuff and one of the topics
that you've worked a lot on when you
were uh with the ACT uh Team folks and
you still are contributing member to
many other papers is look for the mass
of neutrinos I want to ask you sorry to
keep saying I I was going to say as a
legend I'm going to keep stop saying
that I'm just to say as someone who's
been in the field for a long time I'm
not yet as an observer of this field for
a very long time time let's say we are
successful we meaning us on the Simon
Observatory and we measure the mass of
cosmic neutrinos for the first time ever
we have lower limit we have an upper
limit we don't have a detection will our
colleagues in high energy physics
department circles will they believe us
Bruce based on your knowledge of history
and thought of the philosophy of this
field I think frankly it's touch and go
unless it's a really clear measurement
going back in the history
one of the things that you can use both
Cosmic nucleus synthesis say the
formation of helium and detarium in the
early Universe to tell you is the number
of nutrino
species and it was not clear whether
that was three or four or five back
let's say in in the early 70s Dave Shram
and others interpreted the astrophysical
data data and said no it's got to be
three n wasn't clear that anybody
believed that
we now know that it's 3.05 roughly
speaking so it's not four it's not five
a little bit later I use the
astrophysical data just pure CMB and
some other stuff to point out that that
the lab measurement of the lifetime of
the free Neutron was not right didn't
didn't agree with the astrophysical data
to say that was a stone that sank
without a ripple would be an
understatement but later the lab
experiment showed that I was right and
so on so it it it takes a lot of effort
if we publish a let's say a three sigma
measurement that the neutrino mass is
0.0057 plus or minus 0.00 02 whatever
will people get up in arms about it and
and try to improve the lab experiments
to to justify this or to confirm it I I
I don't know there are people like Mike
Turner who work and many others who work
at the interface between cosmology and
particle physics who I think would take
it
seriously but whether your colleagues
down the hall who were big accelerator
guys will I I don't
know I hope we do the experiment that is
I hope we come up with this number and
publish it and say there it is guys
Bruce before I have to go and teach
myself I want to ask you about pedagogy
um you are one of the best Educators uh
not just a cosmology but but you're
you're dedicated your life life um at a
predominantly undergraduate at an
undergraduate serving institution that's
had a a host of eminent scientists come
out of it out of your classes and you
have you know sort of revolutionized and
enhanced the teaching of cosmology at
the undergraduate level I want to ask
you about your theory of pedagogy and in
the following uh sense I teach a lot of
undergraduates and I teach gra uh
graduate students experimentalist I've
had a few theoretical you know gradu
graduate students who are only doing
Theory not experiment what is the
theoretical minimum or shall I say the
experimental minimum what should an
experiment a theoretical grad student
know about experimental physics or
experiment let's just stick to cosmology
what should he or she know she's
starting off she's really excited to
come up with an explanation for the
hemispherical asymmetry the some sterile
neutrino signature in the CMB a large
extra Dimension but what should she know
about experimental astrophysics before
she goes and does everything she's going
to do in theory I would say that the
main lesson to take away and I harp on
this when I talk to to theorists is just
how damn difficult these experiments are
they're not easy you have a big piece of
equipment the size of your lab or bigger
sitting at a temperature of 300 Kelvin
and you're trying to make measurements
of the order of 10 microkelvin without
that piece of equipment it's not easy
guys and given that theorists pay real
attention to the issue of systematics
and instrumental effects don't leave
that to the the instrumentalist think
about it yourself if I see a signal
suppose I suddenly discover a
hemispheric
asymmetry are you really sure that
doesn't have to do with the way your
instrument is designed and the fact that
it happens to be in the Southern
Hemisphere and not the northern it may
be that the answer is okay but think
about it that's what I would tell theis
we always end with a a comment from the
guest on a quote from Sir Arthur C Clark
who's the namesake of the foundation
that endowed the center that I am
affiliated with here in San Diego the
Arthur C Clark Center for human
imagination and Arthur good old Arthur I
don't know if you ever knew him or met
him I didn't I've read his books yeah so
he had uh many many quips and sayings
one of which is the only way to know the
limits of the possible is to go beyond
them into the impossible and that's the
origin of the name of this podcast
another one that I like to use on my
colleagues who think of too highly ofs
is he used to say for every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert but
the question I want you to comment on uh
is the following he said when a
distinguished older scientist says
something is possible he or she is very
likely to be right but when he or she
says something something is impossible
they are very much likely to be wrong
but I want to ask you not if you you
know um if you agree but rather what
have you changed your mind on in this
field of cosmology as our final question
have you been wrong or have you changed
your mind about something that you held
very firmly in your Youth and and yet
change came to your mind the business of
Galaxy formation we had Jim and I had a
particular model in mind and
most people don't believe that so I've
been sort of forced to change my mind
although I haven't really given up on it
the other is dark matter when when
people started talking about Dark Matter
it seemed to be absolutely and totally
ridiculous stuff that we know nothing
about somehow is important in the
universe and I simply refuse to believe
that despite all the good work of Vera
Rubin and people like that showing that
it probably there is something out there
and what finally got me to believe to
believe in
it was
a bibulous conversation with Jerry
ostriker drinking beer on a boat in Lake
Ontario and he said Bruce godamn it if
if you don't see fluctuations at a level
of at least 10 the minus 3 in the
microwave background it's all over well
I'd already done an experiment throwing
the upper limit was less than that so
what was going on well what's going on
is is that the fluctuations in the micro
background are produced by the Barons
and the gravity is mediated by the dark
matter so the dark matter can be happily
gravitating away and not make the
fluctuations that ostriker insisted we
should be seeing so in a sense my own
work came up behind me and kicked me in
the
butt maybe that's a good play to S this
right it is uh well uh I want to thank
you for many things not the least of
which is inspiring me as a as a young
graduate student with that wonderful
book 3K with that horrible cover uh but
uh you made up for it with your book
with Jim Peebles and Lyman page past
guest on the podcast uh finding the Big
Bang we'll put a link to those books in
the show notes and uh Bruce I just want
to thank you uh from the bottom of my
heart for being an Exemplar of what a
good cosmologist should be and being a
mentor and through all your years of
service which we also didn't get to talk
about maybe we'll do this in person
someday a part two but Bruce thank you
thank you so much and I hope you enjoy
the rest of your weekend thank you and
let's join in thanking the Simons
Foundation absolutely thank you Bruce
thanks for watching this interview with
Bruce I hope you enjoyed it I had so
many great takeaways and memories from
this episode I know you will too now on
my YouTube channel I try to give you as
much content as possible but there's so
much more I want to share with you
that's why I'm urging you to subscribe
and join my mailing list at briank
king.com this is where I share the
hottest news in science you'll also
enter a giveaway for a piece of 4
billion year old space dust AKA a
meteorite so if you have a.edu email
address you'll automatically win one but
anyway you can enter to win one no
matter what your email address is just
go to briank king.com sign up thanks
again see you on the other side